was sind das eigentlich für leute die
gerade den schuld vergöttern
wie tickt der gemeine soße können sie
dazu nun eine anthropologie vorlesung
von dr dietmar wischmeyer ma
herrschaften ruhe bitte am äußersten
rand der realität wie wir sie kennen
lebt der sozialdemokrat in seiner partei
der spd kann man viel spaß haben
jeder duzt den anderen und man redet
sich immer mit artikeln an
du bist dann die ingrid oder der helmut
die sozialdemokraten nennt man auch
genossen das ist die vergangenheit form
von genießen
genauso wie wir aus der geschlechtsreife
so sie verbringen fast sein ganzes leben
im sogenannten out verein
er redet über die rente mit 48 und dass
die grünphasen der ampeln viel zu kurz
in felde mitbürger also für alle mord
verein in der bruch zeit immer kurz vor
wahlen kämpft der genosse für soziale
gerechtigkeit nach den wahlen wenn er
mit regiert verkaufte vor allem waffen
nach saudi arabien
dafür hast dass ich selbst zurecht aber
damit ist jetzt schluss denn vom berg
brüssel stieg eine glatze herab und
sprach ist komme aus unserem winter sohn
gottes und kantone parteien zum leben
erwecken und wie die wogen wählten ihn
mit 100 prozent erstaunlich denn selbst
der echte jesus bekamen nur 1 947 weil
einer der zwölf jünger ein verräter war
martin aber gerät nicht vor allem nicht
was er vorhat wenn man ihn welt und so
zieht der weisen will sollte dem esel
weiter über tage lang hält seine
standardrede und immer wenn er die worte
gemeinsam krankenschwester oder
dachdecker ruft dann klatschen alle ganz
laut und die alten genossen im publikum
vor begeisterung ihr letzten sprung
so wie wir heute unser thema nächste
woche lautet die chancen der fdp bei der
bundestagswahl
bitte bringen sie als ihre badehose mit
vielen dank
[Applaus]